[Music]
hey
hello gamers look at this
it looks so good i can watch them suffer
in hd now
i can't believe 40 episodes
and i finally listen it even runs better
look at this
yeah kinda all right we're doing a raid
so i gotta kill all the raiders there's
one right there
yeah i'm doing my part hey
hey you need to start killing them oh
man bro
you don't you don't look too good man oh
no i think
i think you're gonna die i'm digging
your grave
i'll make sure you're honored in death
for your effort okay
there you go isn't that nice yeah i'll
put a little
flower there yeah you
all right cool i don't know if this is
worth it oh god because they have the
axe people and i remember the axe people
do a
ton of damage and oh god he's coming
stop run straight run straight
[Music]
i don't know man uh another one
another one i got away bro you're gonna
make me do all the work
huh agreement for me i can't die if i
die i die
i pew that i die oh they're coming from
here yeah
head shot head shot i'm too good man
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god i got it
[Music]
no no no no no no no i'm out
oh god
okay i just realized
what hit me i'm scared
hello i don't think this is i don't
think this is worth it
oh god oh there's gonna be more now you
know what i'm switching sides
i'm out not worth it
i'm out oh geez
i'm out guys i'm on your side trust me
oh they're all in there
[Laughter]
[Music]
why am i doing this okay i'm out i'm out
i'm not doing this
nope oh it's a shame about the village
it really was a beaut
it really was a beautiful town oh what a
shame dude uh
all right the battle is lost i guess
oh no damn i holy recognize the game i
feel like it gets harder now because i
can't really
see as well as before god damn it looks
better
oh god all right let's just go i'm uh
i'm done and
this place sucks
yeah whoa
try to shoot me through the nether mad
lights all right we're heading back
back to back to base damn even the
nether looks good look at that
yeah bro i got 90 fps what is this
minecraft i'm just having like 12.
it's amazing hey i had a long day
i had a long day don't touch me i can't
do this i don't it's not worth risking
dying at this point
that's what i'm worried
hey yeah okay i'm a carrot what do you
want from me oh
god oh god um i know what i want to do
today instead something more peaceful
we're going to build in another the
other direction and see if we can
actually find something
epic oh god i forgot they attack me
how have i made this this far i don't
know i'm out
home at last yes you are again yes
you're beautiful you however
need a spanking i'm not gonna kill you
oh well one of you
one of you died all right hey don't be
so uptight about it jeez
ah my beautiful home my modern
contemporary minecraft house
yes yes oh
the glass looks better now hey
how you doing man you really like that
spot don't you
hey you're free to go
huh you want to stay there all right you
heard it here first folks
likes it i'm going to bed i think
i want to just get some quick obsidian
so that we can build another portal what
was i doing there you go
so let's just do that real quick look i
found red diamonds right away
hell yeah the torch in my hand lifts up
is this cheating
oh i found brown diamond damn guys
i'm gonna lucky roll what
i found blue diamond but
nice there it is
come on come on come on
all right i'll take it nice i feel like
i can sniff out diamonds you know
oh more diamonds damn the water looks so
good
what's all this fuss about nvidia doing
stuff like this is it
this is better great
thank you lava
come on dude
[Music]
oh i see you
get out of here idiot think he's gonna
kill me
i don't think so this is uh everyone
dies except me
play through everyone else must suffer
now we got some meat
uh to cook you can uh a little pro tip
for you guys
a lot of people don't know you can use a
whole room full of furnaces
yeah a little pro tip for you guys i'll
be done any minute
oh you're a minecraft veteran yeah do
you have a furnace room
it goes much quicker basically okay
i know you have a problem clearly i'm
working on it trust me look at this view
by the way
so nice the sand looks like snow it's
quite festive
all right we're heading out it's another
time i'm not even gonna sleep first
that's how badass i become
sleeping is for cowards what can i say
all right
i have to sacrifice one of you
it was the weakest
okay so i want to find another fortress
this feels like a terrible idea it
really does
just don't look down bro
so we're gonna go in the opposite
direction we'll be fine trust me i can't
die it's fine it's fine trust me trust
me yeah it's cool
that's safe right oh my god is that
another fortress
that looks like something let's keep
going we're using bridges
they're on our side it's all good safety
railings is for cowards
i don't need a safety railing if i'm
dead am i right something to think about
i'm going all balls no skill on this
oh that's further than i thought what is
that that is something it has to be
something
there's another one what is soleil i
kind of want to explore
but i feel like i'm going to die all
right we're going for it
nope no i'm not i'm not going i'm not no
damn this is so cozy
right stop you're not cozy you're ugly
know the difference okay so we're gonna
have to
oh geez that's so far that's fine
i can do it
running long blocks already this is
fantastic god this is the most awful
bridge of all time
uh how much okay what is that what is
that
i never seen those goddamn why is this
so big why isn't it they're so large
can the lava make my bridge burn i don't
think so
this sucks it just sucks it sucks
and strikes with the bee seeds friends
with the trees
wait wait oh a child alone in the forest
picking up berries for a grandad who's
sick
oh something swished past him what could
have been
must have been the wind the wind
oh lucky child
a child will live hey guys sorry about
the kids
well well well we meet again no
not you oh my gosh
a child a child all right
nice now we can make some progress never
mind
are you serious that's fine
just bridge up
why are they jumping all in well do you
see that
[Music]
idiots is this how you minecraft i
forgot
oh wait i can just go up here oh
oh god i didn't see where i was going
okay let's go through the ceiling but we
must be fast cause ceiling gang cringe
ceiling almost killed me dude i knew it
nope no thanks
oh you can hear like radioactive sounds
here i didn't realize that that's kind
of cool
oh my god how do kids play this game
it's terrifying yeah my six year will
play minecraft
oh your six zero is a goddamn hero
oh my god i'm not even near fantastic
amazing yeah this is just what i wanted
no no
no the same the same biome
it's the same okay
all right fine i'll build i'll build
another portal here
just to check it out this has been a
massive failure so far i absolutely
garbage
that's is that correct this doesn't feel
correct to me
oh god they're gonna make fun of me
again there we go boom
all right something cool here we go
what is this actual garbage oh creeper
creeper creepy creeper
take me back this is a swamp why is it
lit there
oh cool the forest the forest is burning
now
that's awesome how is it still night
oh sorry spiders can't swim
i told you bro oh look these are super
rare in animal crossing
too bad we're not playing animal
crossing
i don't i don't know where my portal is
i don't know where i put my portal
stop get me alone
where's my portal oh funny
no nope nope nope oh great
hey welcome to hell you're okay to stay
i'm going back this is a huge failure
how am i supposed to face people at home
oh wait his name is
i'm losing it i'm losing that guy so i
need help oh yeah you're quicker
oh no
how did he even get there all right if i
was a nether fortress where would i be
nowhere apparently nowhere what the flip
is that
that's not even a tree dude what
starting to understand how lucky i was
with my first biome
everyone kept saying it but i didn't
believe it i believe it now
oh oh look at that that's just great
no no die
oh my god i'm amazing never mind
oh my god this is a horror game is it
safe
hello
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
anyway we found one that's cool am i too
low level for this probably no
low skill is the right word anyway here
we go fine this is what i wanted to do
this episode
it took me so long oh belisabees
okay here we go i didn't voice crack
because i'm nervous i voice crack
because i'm a man
and that's what men do thank you thank
you a terrible fortress
we'll see about that thing about these
fortresses is it always impossible
to find the exit oh there's a spawner
are they tough
are you tough are you tough bro are you
tough bro
you tough bro oh we got one we got one
we got one another one
they are very tough what the hell this
is fine
nice we got two sweet come on come on
little
you okay in there but oh i knew it see
one is fine but two is trouble
i don't know how many arrows i have left
yes yes
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of people don't know this oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god
i'm good i'm going to go i don't have
anything uh
what you can't bro you of course you
can't burn it of course you can't burn
it
what can i burn the wood the nice rod i
have to sack one
ah that breaks my heart
damn there was one here uh
where do i go where do i go oh there's
there's one of the evil ones
you can cheese them right yeah
idiot the niece bruh
oh this is the entrance i actually found
my way back holy crap
she says
ah god damn it i don't have more food i
gotta go back
okay we're alive ah
don't hurt me oh jurgen i didn't think i
would see you
again
oh no sorry guys
the stakes are high oh my god it's never
felt so good to be home man
here i'm gonna be nice to you guys for
once every everyone gets to frick
everyone i'm so sorry
i got a new perspective on life now god
damn it looks good dude
hey i can't believe you haven't
despawned yet honestly
all right we got two blaze rods i'll
take i'll take it i'll take it
seems good to me that took a lot of
gamer sweat
[Music]
it tastes better when they're afraid i
can taste their fears
there's one thing i want to do before i
end this episode
first we need sand hey look it's the
y bunny
you're in my domain now you can't escape
don't even try it
ah dude the sunset oh my god it looks so
pretty
yes look at that what a view dude
what do you think ah yes
oh heck yeah all right good thing now we
have our furnace room
they left when i said that remove
furnaces
[Music]
they called me a madman oh this is hella
cozy
oh heck yeah more cozy factor please
close this on pinterest guys oh look at
this
oh smell i feel the warmth
something happened in the nether there i
don't know what happened but a part of
me insanity was lost
let's go to bed while it cooks nothing
like going to bed when the oven is going
uh
see this is the reason why people do
that i did a little bit building off
camera because you're just like
it requires focus you guys just don't
get it
oh that's gonna look nice that's gonna
look really nice dude
there we go it's time come out little
one
oh he's stuck bro why don't you tell me
you were stuck this whole time
uh if i knew no come on come on come on
come on
come on my only friend in this entire
series except jurgen of course
it was actually more important now
hopefully there's no holes in here
there you go you are welcome
no no
[Music]
all right i'm i'm an eye for so there
thank you for watching all this
important this series really helps if
you want to subscribe
like i appreciate it see you next one
for a face